what would you say to Terran back in
2001 Wow now
heels in 2013
God
I would say so much i think but i'm sort
of overwhelmed at the same time my dad
said to me when he was dropping me off
because my parents drove me out to LA it
takes 10 years to become an overnight
success and I sort of I even feel like I
felt at the time us don't say that you
know God forbid it actually takes 10
years or longer you know for for things
to work out and I kind of wish you
hadn't said anything but but it's okay
if I was talking to myself then I think
I would have said
make your own movies faster you know I
look at I look at someone like Joe
Swanberg and I watched pretty much
everything he does I don't know why it
just resonates me with me or whatever
but I I look at him and I and I can
think back when he was at south by
southwest in it was 2005 I know what I
was doing in 2005 because I had made a
film in like 2003-2004 and but Joe's
film was successful and ours really
wasn't and it was there were two
different types of films do no one else
I go that's interesting I don't know i
think i would have told myself produced
your own work faster I like write it if
you're writing it not improving it and
make it and get it out there and then do
it again and then do it again and also
don't lose focus don't get caught up
keep your goals front of minds like if
if you want to be an actress don't go a
year without having acted you know
you have to not it's easy i think in LA
you know I've seen it I've experienced
it myself where you'll be in a day job
for example and you get in a rhythm and
you can support yourself but you look up
one day and you're like what have I
accomplished
it's a great question and it's hard to
answer and but it's good to answer
because then you remember oh yeah that
is not at all what I came out here for
and of course we all have to live and
eat and have a roof over our heads and
all of that but at the same time you
need to figure it out you need to figure
out how you're going to shoot on
weekends and get it done
get something as a can and get it out
there you know because that's why you're
here it says
you